[Music]
welcome to lighting talks I'm super
excited to be here today and talk to you
about how to welcome your users to your
Android app when they get a new phone so
why is this important so if you think
about the Android ecosystem it runs on
phones right we all get a new phone
every two maybe three years and when we
do this we reinstall all of the apps
we've installed and we do this and all
of our users of our app to do this as
well you do a little bit of math you
figure out if you buy a new phone every
two years that means half of your users
are gonna get a new phone this year if
you you know don't do anything at all
with your application you're gonna give
them a cold welcome when they come back
and you're gonna show them an email and
a password form that's gonna be like
they've never used your app before
you're completely disrupting their flow
of using your app what you want to do
instead is offer them a warm welcome you
want to welcome them back to your
application and create this continuous
user experience that jumps from their
old device to their new device so you
don't have any friction you don't have
any retention problems for these users
that are switching devices and using
your application there's a couple
products you can use from Google that
help you do this so one of them is
Google sign-in I think everyone knows
what Google sign-in is right it's a
button you press and you login all right
so it's a button you press and you login
it's amazing for this flow exactly
because it's very simple to do that
login so it's good for your activation
originally because it's easy to log into
your app but when they get a new phone
it's also good for reactivating these
users because all they do have to is
have to click a button and on Android
you can even configure it so they don't
even have to click the button on the new
device they'll automatically log in
Google sign-in works on iOS Android as
well as the web so you can use it
everywhere and it's a great way to add
federated login to your application
another feature you can use on Android
is smart lock for passwords so smart
lock is well it's a password manager
it's named quite well so it stores
usernames and passwords or even
federated credentials up in the cloud
when the user confirms that they would
like to save the password after they log
in so they're gonna do this on their old
phone they're gonna save their password
and then when they get onto their new
device when they first come into your
application you're gonna give them this
warm welcoming to say I know who you are
I do you want to login with that account
you've already saved for this
application and it's just going to
create that seamless experience and log
that user into your application so one
of our our partners Netflix who I
believe is here today actually
so Netflix use this and they found that
they had 20% fewer support requests so
if you think about that you know maybe
every time a user contacts you to you
know get a username and password fix
this probably five users that didn't and
they're just not gonna come back to your
application for months or even years at
a time
they might just you know become a
retention problem them and never come
back so this is a fantastic way to
improve your business metrics and then
autofill is a new feature we launched in
Android Oh it works kind of like smart
lock when it comes to usernames and
passwords so it's an autofill system
right so it auto fills text views
exactly the way you think and one of the
most common text views to get auto
filled is usernames and passwords so the
way this works is after they log into
your application on their old device
they'll choose to save it to the
autofill service and that's going to go
up to the same data store as smart lock
it's a secure data store from passwords
and then when they come back on their
new device it's just gonna go ahead and
autofill so there's a couple things you
can do to get your application ready for
autofill one of the biggest ones is set
up a digital asset link that links your
web and your Android app so this is
great because autofill has pluggable
password managers but all of the
password managers support this and when
they do that what happens is the user
can log in on the web and if they're
using the same password manager on their
Android device they're gonna go ahead
and get those credentials transferred so
they log in on the web install your
Android app and the passwords already
saved that gets a seamless upgrade
experience to your Android application
another thing you have to do for
autofill well you don't have to do it
but if you want the best experience for
users you should setup autofill hints so
you should tell the autofill service
what's the user name what the password
field is that way the autofill service
doesn't have to guess based on your IDs
and maybe get it wrong which is you know
probably the worst experience you can
give your users and then the last thing
we're gonna talk about is auto backup I
might hand it over to Jeremy yeah so
auto backup is a great way to also
provide continuity to your users so even
if your app syncs to the cloud there's
still usually device specific settings
that you can backup and there's also you
know
user who's been using your app for a
year wants to see a tutorial first thing
when they launch your app when they're
on a new phone so Auto Backup works by
when the phone's idle we back up to the
cloud your data is stored securely you
can have up to 25 Meg's but if you go
over that backups will fail on the new
phone where the user installs the app it
will restore the data before the app
runs for the first time and the user
picks up where they left off without any
friction or churn you can also include
and exclude specific files so for
example you can exclude ooofff tokens or
other things that shouldn't be backed up
and with all these tools is possible to
provide continuity to your users and
keep them engaged when they switch
phones will be back in the back
[Music]